It doesn't matter who I am
What matters
Is the Plan
No one cared who I was
until I put on the hat
AAAAHH!!!!
Alright.....
Gotta do everything again!
hhhh
haha...
I don't even know if I r-
*Dies*
I don't even know if I remember!
Clearly...
Oh, my god...
Okay! Here we are at the balls, everybody!
The ball game.
Easiest one!
Go go go go! There's an opening!
Bababababa!
Damn it !
Babababababababa!!
Bababa!
Ba! *Dies*
Bababababababa!
Come on, man!
*High-pitched voice* Come on, Poodiepie! You can do it!
Hey! Look at that!
Ok, great! Let's do all of that again!
Yes!!
YES!!
HOORAH!
Okay. Alright, I remember this.
Dammit.
Dammit!
And you have to go UP...
and then DOWN super fast!
Ooh!
OH, I did it!!
OH, MY GOD! He's the best!
And then there was this bit...
*Goes into insanity*
No!
NO!!
STOP!
STOOOOP!!
You know what never gets old?
Repetition.
DU!
DUAH!!
You know what never gets old?
Repetition.
DU!
DUAH!! (Deja vu)
DUAH!! (Ooh! Times two!)
You know what never gets old?
Repetition.
*lol jk*
*Failed attempt to sing theme music*
*Dies inside*
Bababababa!!
Ahh, there you go!
That's very nice!
No!
Suck on my toes!!! Can you not? Can you not?
(cute voice)
Can you just not...
Can you not do that, pleaasee?
Plea- *dies in game*
*poods fan* Can you not do that, please?
Pleassee!
PLEASEE!!!
Aaaahhh
This part is easy.
Honestly, if you die in this bit, you can
lick on my turtle neck.
Gooo... Look at that, look at that boy! Hey, you wanna follow me?
Guess what, you can't!
Stupid, this bit is super easy, unless you're pathetic, little moron!
Pathetic, little degenerate son of a *pause*
Easy, this is easy is what I am trying to say.
*talks to the game*
You are gonna come here and I am gonna eehh
*screeches again* eahhh
ahhhhhh
YES!
Then you can su..
Everyone can suck on my toes.
Everyone
Please stand in ..
LINE!
Oh! I forgot to bomb it.
Ooh!
Alright, here we go! Come on
brahhhhh!
You didn't bomb all of it!
You brahhhhhhh *screams*
Here we go.
Look at that
Look at guys, we did it
yatta.
やった すごい です ね
Yatta sugoidesu ne (It was amazing)
すごい
sugoi (amazing)
Alright as soon as it jumps,
we are gonna go!
Brrrr aaahhhh stop!
Go, GO!
I F___ING HATE THIS BIT! (Christian channel everybody)
Ahhhhh ehherw
Ah!
*Laughs*
I'm playing on an iPad. I'm a gaming channel, guys
You know what I really like? Repetition
You know what I also really like? Repetition
You know what I really really
stfu!
Alright, here's the ball bit, everyone!
Everyone loves the BALL BIT!!
Stupid balls ruin my life... Go! *dies*
Damn balls! Come on, balls! Show me what you got them, balls! Come on, balls!
Come on, balls! Is that all you got, balls?
brrrrrrr brrr
Oh My God, can you
suck on my toes? I just pretend I'm not as good as I am for the sake of entertainment value. Look at that!
Look at this! First try!
First try! I am in my little submarine now, guys! First try! Please subscribe
to PewDiePie
Oh god, alright, first try everybody!
Subscribe to PewDiePie for more epic gaming channels like this one. Look at that! First try! Not even- I did it blindfold
Ok alright alright.
This part is a little tricky
If you're a moron... Look at this!
Look at this! Dahhh!
Dahhh!
Ahhh! Skill...
I know, I know what you're thinking - "How is he so great and good-looking at the same time?" Well, you know it comes from...
*dies at the game*
This bit can just-
Look at it! Look at it! Okay...
Aahh... Ahhhh... AH! AAAH!
Alright I get it... We are gonna drop one there...
Why?! Forgot abou- No, no, I'm not gonna...
Aaahhh!
Look at that! You can suck on my ninja turtles! Damn it! NOOO!
This pathetic disgusting snotty noise
Pimple-faced vader gamers... I can't even beat a game and get all angry
Pathetic... Trurly pathetic...
Look at me do this on the actually very first try. Oh, the ball bit! Some people say the ball bit is difficult... If you're a moron,
perhaps, I could agree
Look how easy this is
No! Can you edit it in so I do it on the first try? Here we go!
Finally! Good job! Can you start moving?
God dammit!
What are you doing?!
STOOOOOP!!!
What-?! If you do that again, I swear I'm gonna get REALLY ANGRY!
Come on!
*high-pitched voice* Here we go, guys!
Let's freakin' do this!
AAAHHH!
AAAAAAAAHHHHH!!!
BA!
KRA!
PRA!
What the f- Just...
*demonic laugh*
Hello, everybody, epic gamer
69 here! Let's begin this video starting off right
(Poods What are you doin?)
Stop judging me. I'm not lying, alright? I'm starting now. Welcome! I've just started playing this game
Let's begin the gameplay! Wow! This game is so easy! How could anyone suppose you can't beat this game? You'd have to be a complete moron
Today is the day
Did it!
I bet you, Jacksepticeye could never beat this game. Look at this!
Look at it!
Look at it! I'm on the roll, baby! I'm always on a roll!
I'm always on a- NO!
Edit that out! Edit that out! I'm on a roll, baby!
Zero deaths, everybody! This is incredible! Never done before! Look at that!
Look at that! I'm not even a gaming channel anymore and I can still beat any game at any given point
with my
superior skill and it- GHAAA!
GO!
And superior handsomeness
Look at that, dude! Look at that, my dudes! Drop the bomb and go through
GO! YES! Oh! OH!
I have never made it this far.
Oh my god! Oh my god, guys, I have never made it this far! Oh my god, guys! Can
we hit and leave a like of this video right now? This is so epic! I need to actually blow
my nose so that doesn't happen again, because that was disgusting
Where did he go? When will he return?
The prophecy states that a time will come when our-
The f*** you say about me, boy?!
Dude, even the music changed... How epic is this!
Alright, so this is easy. It's gonna be the classic sliding bit where you slide off the...
...the pad. I'm not gonna slide off because I'm not an idiot.
Oh my god! This is so... Damn it! Stop sliding!
Oh, oh! Where the hell did the platform go? Oh, it melts!
Damn it!
Come on!
No!
NO!
Stop!
Stop killing meeee!
MMMMHHHH!!!
I lost all the progress. I have to do all of that again. That's great. That's great. I'm great. Before you, men I'm glad. That's-
Oh, look, I level up, everyone.
Here we are again, Mr. Iceman!
Haha!
So, we meet again?
Our battle begins! Jump! Jump! Damn it!
Our battle continues! Jump! Jump!
Ahhh! Don't go in the- !
Her battle continues, my friend! Jump! Jump!
Our battle begins!
Ju-
Can you get inside him?!
Come on...!
It's not even hard! It's not even freakin' hard! Why are you going there?!
Hahaha!
Positive attitude, guys! Let's believe! Press- Press like if you believe, guys!
You didn't believe hard enough... Don't you feel ashamed?
So, we meet again, Mr. Ice!
Hop! Hop! Hop!
Damn it!
No!
Come on! You can do this, feller! *high-pitched voice* Come on, feeler! Come on, feeler, we believe in you! I'm trying!
AAAAAAAAAAHHHHH!
EEERGH! Easy...!
Oh my god! This game is so easy!
Ah, the easy sliding technique!
Pew! Pew! Pew!
Pew!
Great...
Pew! Pew!
PEW! PEW!
Hey, look at that! First try, everyone! I am practically a genius! What is this?
What is-? I'm serious. What is this?
What the hell am I supposed to do here? What the hell is this? What do I do?
WHAT DO I DOOOOO?
I am inside him
What do I do! Oh my god! I'm supposed to shoot him! Die! Dammit!
I'm gonna... Die-
D-d-di- Oh!!! No!!!
No!
*struggles*
GHA!
Oh!
Yeah!
Anyway, guys, hope you enjoyed this video! If you did... hehehe
Anyway, guys, honestly, it means the world to me if you would leave like on this video. Perhaps, share it with your friends
Show your support for the gaming of this channel! Let's #bringbackpewdiepiegaming!
If you want more epic gaming montages like this one, make sure that you
watch another one and another one. Never stop.
What else you gonna do with your life? Honestly, you made it this far in the PewDiePie video. Honestly...
It's pathetic!
Anyway, brofist!